victorias schicksalshaften 8 ein moment
der wahrheit für die hauptfigur und für
das film experiment schlechthin
beim dritten und letzten tag muss es
einfach klappen bis zum letzten tag war
unsere realität oder meine wurde es
immer mehr das wird nicht gehen
wie konnte ich konnte ich nur glauben
dass das irgendwie den raum
die zweifel sind berechtigt folgt die
kamera der jungen spanierin doch durch
die nacht ohne pause ohne einen schnitt
da muss alles stimmen einsam in berlin
trifft sie auf vier sympathische
verlierer manche leute sagt jahres sowie
theater und ich denke mir so es ist das
totale gegenteil von theater da ist
normales film drehen mehr theater das
ist nicht theater weil wir das in zwei
stunden nonstop gedreht haben weil die
kamera das ding da das ist dass das
beobachtet eines riecht ein
das ist das ist eine waffe dass die
schauspieler also dass ich die dahin
bekommen habe aber auch dass die die
begabung hatten und den willen sich
darauf einzulassen
das ist ja der wahnsinn ich gesagt ihr
müsst das empfinden
ihr könnt es nicht spielen ihr müsst das
empfinden diese nächsten zwei stunden
die sind für euch wir wissen dass es
eine story auch aber das ist auch
gleichzeitig was ihr nicht empfinden
das kann ich nicht empfinden irgendwann
vergisst man dass da nicht geschnitten
wird und lässt sich von moment zu moment
mit ziehen
ein scheitern der übung droht in jedem
moment das pusht das ganze team zu
höchstleistungen
der regisseur dabei verdammt zum
zuschauen und hoffen
meine position eins als regisseur in dem
film viel mehr wie von dem sänger so ein
fußballtrainer
also ich kann mit den trainieren und ich
kann mir ein system ausdenken wie die
spielen sollen aber ich weiß auch dass
mein spielsystem was ich mir ausgedacht
habt nur mit den besten der besten
möglich ist
da costa und fördere glory von ihr
bestes spiel
alle dialoge improvisiert und auch unter
druck unglaublich locker
keine ahnung aber ich habe ja auch zum
ersten mal dialoge hab ich nicht
geschrieben also dialoge haben die halt
improvisieren aus leichtigkeit wird bald
ernst das zusammengewürfelte team
versucht sich an einem bankraub
adrenalin angst eins zu eins spürbar
victoria ist ein filmischer rausch und
von kamera über regie schauspiel
mehrfacher favorit für den deutschen
filmpreis
auf der einen seite was tolles
ausgedacht auf der anderen seite auch
das hirn riesiges und das zieht es aber
irgendwann so angenommen haben und das
dann konnten es ist auch noch immer
wieder was was mich total berührt
notfalls hätte er auch geschnitten denn
die gefühle sind entscheidend das ist ja
der wahnsinn
wir haben das geprobt so dann haben wir
drei mal gedreht
das heißt ich habe jeder einzelne szenen
des films hatte ich schon ein paar mal
vorher gesehen und es gibt nicht eine
einzige szene also jede szene in diesem
letzten tag ist auf die beste art und
weise wie es sie je gesehen hat
und dennoch will sebastian schipper nie
mehr einen film ohne einen schnitt
machen
dieses experiment soll einmalig bleiben